yo my whole life is dedicated to change  hi I'm Ryan Lochte and I'm an Olympic  swimmer and my favorite movie is belly  belly is my favorite movie because it  has the best opening scene and it's a  straight gangster movie like me after  that movie  I feel live really energized my heart's  beating and I feel like I could conquer  anything in a weird twisted way the  movie belly kind of has a purpose to it  for me I took from it is nothing will  stand in my way I will always try to  achieve my goals and there's nothing  gonna be that's gonna stop me I'm gonna  keep going until I reach it I think  that's the only way to live as an  Olympic athlete you have a goal this  goal is like a highway you can't stop  off for gas or anything you got to just  keep going  I'm Ryan Lochte and I love movies  you